haha the suit came in oh yes I upped it
not to put the coat on tonight maybe
next time but up to a wonderful
two-parter very well regarded and yeah I
was looking forward to getting back into
this one human nature and the family of
blood now before we get too far along
this is a sponsored video sponsored by
the podcasts radio versus the Martians
I don't mind plugging them because not
only do I know that they're awesome and
I was listening to them long before they
were sponsoring me but you know it's a
podcast so I'm not asking you to spend
money on them just give them a listen to
talk about all sorts of crazy nerdy
stuff
Casey Doran and Mike Gillis they will
have guests on and they'll talk about
everything from Batman to Star Trek to
Star Wars to just a whole cavalcade of
stuff wherever their brains wander to
which goes some interesting places
sometimes they ask interesting questions
they obsess over Arnold Schwarzenegger
go check out Radio versus the marshes
calm or wherever you happen to listen to
a podcast so that out of the way let's
talk about this one this is yeah this is
one of the really beloved stories and I
mean why wouldn't it be this is just
well-constructed well paced well cast
well acted across the board this whole
thing is just really really terrific
like to the point that it's hard to know
where to start
I even like complimenting it normally I
say where do I start that's usually a
bad sign he's like God I got so many
things to complain about that's that's
not what's going on here
so the the general setup of the doctor
being human and not even realizing who
he actually is
that's um
that's something that could have felt
really contrived and honestly like if
there's one if I've got one complaint
about this is that the cold-open is very
weak but that's kind of just the nature
of the story there's nothing there it
starts out completely ordinary that's
kind of the point so but it is a little
bit weird that you just have the doctor
looking at a newspaper that's me
completely human and a little smile and
then the big dramatic is like boy
normally we come in at a dramatic can
the doctors fix the situation thing but
everything seems fine odd but I mean
like I said that's that's a nitpick and
that was basically for want of a
criticism somewhere because otherwise I
I don't really have them which is weird
for me well now I do have one other one
but I will come back to that so in any
case what I really love about the
performance of David Tennant in this
playing John Smith I'm and also the
doctor but the doctors not him this all
that much is kind of what I've already
alluded to in the very way in which I'm
talking about this John Smith is a very
different character from the doctor he
he feels very distinct yet at the same
time not like a total abandonment of who
the doctor is and I really like that
because he's close enough to the doctor
to remind you of the doctor but then at
various points very clearly
distinguishes himself from freezing in
the sight of danger to having a bit more
of a legitimately cowardly instinct to
the moment where like one student in the
in the school that he teaches that asked
for permission to beat another student
and he grants it and you know that's not
something the doctor would have done but
it's something John Smith would do and
one of the things I in addition to the
way that he's distinguished from the
doctor one of the other things I really
like about this is and this happens for
both John Smith and John Redfern who is
fantastic character and incredibly well
played as well is that they both feel
like good people of their
time.they it's it's always interesting
to me when we get these historical set
things and this isn't restricted to
Doctor Who but it's not uncommon for us
to get these historically set things
that gloss over or try to avoid or in
some way have a character recognize that
they are right just what were the
natural inequities of the time which you
know would have been in regards to
classism racism misogyny and things of
that nature they're all present a little
bit but they're present because that was
the world of 1913 in England they would
be there but what I like about it is
more often than not when most things and
again I actually don't think Doctor Who
is one of the bigger offenders of this
but I mean well like the most laughable
example of what I'm about to talk about
comes from the film the patriot which
was a Mel Gibson film but I'm not sure
that many people will remember I
actually kind of enjoy it but in any
case it's set during the American
Revolution and early on some British
people come to the plantation that Mel
Gibson's character runs and the this
British guy tries to recruit what he
believes to be the slaves and they're
like we're not slaves who we work this
land as freemen and that kind of became
a joke because it's like no the guy
would have had slaves like pretending
that that wasn't the case doesn't is not
to anybody's benefit and there seems to
be a reluctance often at times to depict
time periods accurately specifically in
regards to characters that we are meant
to be rooting for so oftentimes the hero
characters in these sorts of stories can
end up being people ahead of their time
very progressive for the time basically
progressive by today's standards so
preposterous ly progressive by the
standards of the time what I like about
this is not only does it not do that but
it kind of emphasizes like that does not
make them bad people Joan Redfern John
Smith even the headmaster honestly are
good people in a time where being a good
person meant something different than it
does now but they you know they are
people who at their core are good decent
people who want good things and and it
balances that really well I spent longer
talking about this point and i think is
actually warranted so we'll move along
how about we talk villains how about we
talk about the family of blood which
first of all the son of mine played by
the same guy who played Viserys
Targaryen which is still my favorite
deaths from Game of Thrones I just not
necessarily like the the most oh it's
about time cuz some of them yeah but
like I still have his dad I really do
anyway that's another show I am just I'm
just tangent left and right to on this
one I don't know what's going on but in
any case so he's great he has this
wonderful not he just slightly off
delivery whether it is with his tone a
lot of has to do with the rhythm of his
speech he'll fail to pause between
certain things or put a pause were like
there's no reason to put a pause between
those words and not like a super long
woman but just enough to break up his
speech in a way that like that's not
right and so he works really well is
sort of the focal point although mother
of mine is is also quite good as well a
father of mine sister of mine they're a
little bit more generic we don't get as
much from them the actors I don't think
but they get the job done and the four
of them together are great I also quite
like the Scarecrow's which I think a lot
of that just has to do with the
visualization cuz otherwise they're just
fodder and they under other
circumstances they might have bothered
me but they weren't from me pretty well
here and I love the emphasis that the
family Blood hunts by smell and all that
and because the thing is a sharp inhale
that's a that can really rack your
attention to that between the flaring
and the nostrils and the and the sound
of your oh oh god they're here so that's
quite cool and I rather like that as
well
and I'm really glad that this was done
as a two-parter because for this to work
at all we need to buy the relationship
between John Smith and Joan Redfern and
I think trying to cram this into a
single piece it just wouldn't have
pulled together and it would the did the
romance especially would have felt
undercooked and thankfully that's not
the case because if we don't care about
these two people and their connection in
their relationship then we're not gonna
care about the climax of this film but
we do and I think a lot of that is
there's a lot of emphasis put on the
that the losing John Smith is going to
be a debt and that's acknowledge both
before and after I really love with the
doctor talking to I mean like spoilers
duh sometimes I bring this sometimes I
say that sometimes I don't but like come
on yeah so I really love the doctor
talking to Joan and she says can you
turn back yes we'll you know and just
sort of from her perspective his
selfishness at letting John die for him
when all he was ever prepared to do was
hide but to come back to that hiding I
also quite like the notion that the
doctor goes through all of this all this
trouble this bother this grief that
Marth is gonna have to deal with all
just to stop himself from being as cruel
as he knows he will if if the family
catches him and he's forced to actually
actively deal with them you know from
I'm sure from the family's perspective
of these like letting them die because
you know that if they don't get a hold
of him they're gonna run down their
lifespans but like that's a natural
progress of time death if he actually
has to stop them he's gonna do something
cruel and he tries very hard to not
be in a position where he's gonna do
that and I I like that
quite a bit as well I also I I like
Timothy who is the the the young man who
finds the watch he has a little bit of a
psychic thing which when those first
mentioned like that's a little bit plot
convenient but at the same time he moves
enough of the plot and and has a big
enough function and the whole thing that
I'm like yeah okay I'll actually forgive
you that and also he does I can't
remember if I'd forgotten this her never
noticed it but he flees the impending
battle when the family of blood and the
scarecrows are getting ready to sort of
assault the school and his schoolmate
calls him a coward
and he calls back yes every time that's
what the ninth doctor said when the
Emperor Dalek called his bluff about the
delta-wave back in back in the
conclusion of series one and the dark
said coward every time that was a that
was a nice little callback so I quite I
quite enjoyed catching that again I
can't remember if I never caught it
before or if I just forgotten could have
gone either way with that I did mention
there was one other thing for me to
nitpick at and it's something that is
not strictly speaking the fault of this
episode because it's just it's just
what's going on this season and Martha
pining for the doctor to the point of
actually vocally bemoaning how he fell
in love with a human in it wasn't her
and you know saying to his face you know
I I love him to bits
or saying to John Smith at least and
this wouldn't have bothered me I don't
think if they hadn't already been
beating this drum so heavily since
basically Epis ekend episode with him
like they went here really
fast and so if this story had really
been the first time that it was made
obvious and it had felt like more of a
build-up to this that could have been a
bit more of a culmination but instead it
just feels like yeah Martha we know but
like it's not gotten to oh and the other
thing that I actually realized watching
this I realized another lay of why this
bothers me aside from the fact that I
don't like a broadly speaking I don't
really like people follow the companies'
falling for the doctor anyways but the
thing is the doctors not looking for
anything like that he had found that
with Rose also not really intending to
find it there but like he really doesn't
want that here but Martha does now again
there's a certain as especially if
you're taking the doctor companion
relationship as a any kind of metaphor
for an actual romantic relationship
there's a certain reality to that you
have a bad breakup and you know you meet
someone else but like what you want you
can't have something deep you are not
prepared to deal with that but they may
or may not still feel that so I'm like I
I recognize the emotional reality of
that but I still don't like and I
realized that another reason why I don't
like that in addition to the many
reasons I just already don't like that
is that it does feed into the worship of
the doctor because I I've mentioned this
a couple times I think I mentioned it
most predominantly when I talked to like
a last year I think when I talked about
the differences between classic and new
WHO and one of the big ones was this
sort of putting up on a pedestal and
worshiping the greatness that is the
doctor is very much a modern who thing
and I feel like this feeds into this
this idea of he's not even trying but
they're gonna fall for him anyways and
and you know and again like I said I I
recognize there's some emotional truth
to that but it just I don't like it in
and of itself if he's into this other
thing that I'm like yeah and also Tim P
has a
a little bit of a monologue thing you
know he's he's wonderful in these grades
and he's terrible and he's amazing the
most incredible man ever I'm like okay
enough enough enough enough enough look
I love I love this show I love the
doctor but come on so having now gone on
for a little bit nitpicking I let me now
acknowledge very openly these are knit
picks these are minor things minor
issues this is a great story with
fantastic acting and it is tragic and it
is touching and it is heartbreaking at
times and it's scared because the family
blood is legitimately unsettling at
points and it's got great I love the
scarecrows as to war track it's a it's a
great kind of slightly more low-key
number four for Doctor Who but I really
like that one it's got a terrific
supporting cast it's well paced this is
just good stuff so that'll wrap it up a
for human nature and the family of why
did I say it like that have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about a
whole bunch of stuff to do because
there's buttons links there is a patreon
I know I have a sponsor but you know the
help is appreciated so I take a look at
that other links down there besides they
take you places click on them or don't
if you really don't want to that's ok
cuz at the end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]